okay I've been listening to a podcast on
Zodiac killer for like the last two
hours straight I'm all worked up and
there's only one thing I can do to work
myself back down and that's to cook cuz
I can't do it well and it's wildly
humbling and that evens me out no time
for another hellofresh video which I
cook at things that they send me and I
show you how easy it is to do on your
own by comparison of how badly I do it
on my own
oh hi my name is Kurt some people don't
know you know your life is different now
for those that don't know hello fraiche
is a brand I work with consistently
because well it's the only consistent
thing in my world oh that's sad and
sweet hello fresh mix cooking delicious
meals at home a reality regardless of
your comfort level in the kitchen I'm
very comfortable in the kitchen
physically doing cooking in the kitchen
ooh discomfortable hellofresh is a
subscription meal delivery service they
send you recipes and the things to make
said recipes in a box so it's like a
foolproof way of proving that a year
domestically an unchallenged boost done
with domestic strife and who's ready to
domestic thrive that's not any of their
official blog life that's just me
quacking up dumb it got family meals
calories smart meals vegetarian options
and they have fun menu series like Hall
of Fame and craft burgers and if I know
what's trendy right now its Fame and
crafting and best of all it's super
flexible you can change your delivery
days if you want to you can change your
food preferences you could skip a week
whenever you want I'm closing that
window because I thought I heard my
neighbor outside and as much as I'm
comfortable doing this in front of
thousands of strangers I will not do it
in front of one person that's live next
to me for two and a half going on three
years at boundaries can you believe it
okay let's get into the cooking of this
he sent me three recipes that I already
picked my favorite one you get no say in
this this is not a democracy today we're
going to try and make a teriyaki beef
and broccoli teriyaki eat beef and
broccoli that sounded cute first like
all good chefs we must prep both
we cook got rid of all my shot glasses
in an effort to be classier but turns
out that won't stop me Cheers
that's what I call preheating and of it
everybody is gone get worse and we're
off everything you need to make this
meal comes in this brown paper bag this
is the kind of brown paper bag you want
to show up on your doorstep the ones
that are on fire that haven't been
scheduled no no and like you guys
already know every recipe card has six
steps with six visual aids I usually
fish up at some point along the way and
this is where this becomes interactive
fun the built-in drinking game is too
right now say out loud in your head
write it down
which number step do you think I'm gonna
push up and if and when I do you get to
drink or drink for all the other stuffs
that i surprisingly don't shove this is
where you kind of get to make the game
yours Hey oh you look so dainty and I
know you're gonna bully me
yeah wait I shouldn't have touched you
already along with everything they send
you it tells you on the side to bust out
all of these things that they presume
you have at home that I constantly never
check before and so let's see I have all
of them oh I'd like to jinx this but I
think this is gonna be the best one yet
step 1 wash and dry all produce god damn
it I already took my own shower today
and that was a lot so here we go
wash and dry I'll produce you look clean
enough you're gonna get peeled you're
gonna get eaten from the inside it's
just you look at this tiny colander
doesn't it look like a little trophy
like I won first place in draining you
of your energy why are you here Rafi
shower the other caveat is that this is
going in my body and not yours
so all your criticisms about my methods
in which I handle food and cooking in my
own home can sit and spin I washed my
hands earlier today so cut broccoli
florets into bite-size pieces yeah we're
gonna do this with our hands get in
there I forgot that cooking makes me so
impatient and really the byproduct of it
should be therapeutically relaxing this
body energy no shoulders are already up
now we're going to peel and min
or great our ginger this is what ginger
looks like if you didn't know ginger
looks like a prehistoric toad I think
negative about that I don't want to
mince this because I'm lazy so I'll
break it I don't mince words cuz I'm
great uncomfortably confident zest and
quarter of a lime alright yeah zest
going on quarter the lime I've change
for a dollar
yeah I got some quarters now thinly
sliced chili removing seeds for less
heat in Li slice this chili and the
seeds are where the heat is stored in a
chili so I'm gonna take that out of here
oh there's so many seeds inside of it oh
you little shot today mother you're like
a little Trojan horses body pain yeah if
the knife is far away from us so we're
gonna wash our hands very aggressively
because sometimes we diddle after we
cook and this would cause a problem
that's not gonna make step one is
officially done you know what that means
drinking game has no rules and all of
the rules Cheers
yep - we're gonna cook the rice we're
going to heat a drizzle of oil in a
small pot over medium-high heat we're
gonna add half the ginger and cook until
fragrant twenty or thirty seconds then
add the rice 1 and 1/4 cups water and a
big pinch of salt we're gonna bring it
to a boil and cover and reduce to a low
simmer and we're gonna cook until rice
is tender 15 to 18 minutes keep covered
off heat until ready to serve I'm
waiting for it to boil so I can simmer
it before I move on to step 3 because I
want to feel like I officially
accomplished this step so I can indulge
genuinely in my own drinking game I make
my own rules that play by my own rules I
abide by their own rules I'm the best
and the worst how are you guys I forgot
that one of the initial desires for this
sort of cooking series was so that we
could have our own little cooking
intimate hangout uh could you pass over
this week what you cook this week I put
all out in the comments down below
because it's better out than in like
Shrek everything bench shrek is like
no I can't I'm not gonna go there we're
officially done step two I'm cooking God
and nailing this I'd like to thank all
of the step twos out there that have
really allowed me to do what I'm doing
now which is moving on to step three you
know rinse repeat
you're my favorite step two step three
we're going to cook our broccoli we're
gonna heat a large pan over medium-high
heat add our broccoli a tablespoon of
water we're gonna cover and let steam
until bright green four to five minutes
I'm always very confused about when they
describe it as medium-high heat it's not
medium as a high to medium-high which is
usually my response after I smoke when
someone asks me how I'm doing I say
medium-high
still got it what are we doing my camera
already shut off I've been recording for
30 minutes already I thought this was
gonna go a lot faster I'm being a Jed we
have a rice coming out of broccoli going
after 4 to 5 minutes we are going to add
some oil salt and pepper to the broccoli
and then we're gonna cook till tender
for another two to four minutes I'm
gonna take a break well this finishes
steaming and then we'll be right back
okay so here's where we're at
I definitely listen to more of the
zodiac podcast in this break and that
didn't help me steam the broccoli and
then we cooked it uncovered with a large
drizzle of oil and salt and pepper for
two to three minutes until it was
charred and slightly soft and now we've
taken that out of the pan and we're on
the step for this it's a long white hair
that was on this glass uh-oh have I aged
that much and how long does it's taken a
powder stay dry we're gonna season
heavily all over with salt pepper and
then we're gonna put some more oil in
the pan that we cooked the broccoli in
we're gonna put this steak and and cook
without stirring until well browned for
three to five minutes and we're gonna
continue to cook stirring occasionally
until cook through two to three minutes
more okay you are compromised you need
to leave what does that be the best way
to tell like someone that's way too
drunk at a party that they need to go
home you're compromised you need to
leave I need to break it up like tips
but any time
that's too much fun together I want to
break it up okay the race seems done I'm
gonna let that sit covered until we're
ready for the rest of the meal meanwhile
what are we doing after it's been will
Hannah Brown for three to five minutes
we're gonna stir it occasionally until
it's cooked through for two to three
more minutes okay we're on to step 5 but
we have to make this quick because there
are things that need to happen while
that thing is happening and everything
is happening and it's all happening and
this is the joy of cooking from home
we're gonna add ginger to the pan of
diced steak and cook until fragrant 30
seconds to 1 minute then we're gonna add
teriyaki sauce and as much lime juice as
we've won stir in broccoli until warm
through turn off heat okay I'm gonna add
more ginger and that's what they said
about Gilligan's Island this is a video
for old people I should have made a
Spice Girls joke it should have been
that's what they said about the Spice
Girls when they wrote the spice world
movie okay now there's something for
everyone all right step five is
officially done you know step six
finish and serve fluff rice with a fork
and stir in one tablespoon of butter and
lime zest to taste oh [ __ ] me where's my
butter I don't have any knives they're
elsewhere I have no time to look for the
knife so we need a tablespoon of butter
I mean this is how Rachael Ray does it
lime zest to taste we season with salt
and pepper here we go come back my one
and only giant utensil and it says
divide the rice between balls and top
with the broccoli at stake mixture if
you like spicy food sprinkle with as
much chilli as you'd like so I don't
need this is optional but chilli was
optional the whole time but Chili's been
optional the whole time thank you for
entertaining me but not to harken back
to MTV's greatest dating show of all
time next okay I'm gonna set this dish
it should be set for two people I'm
gonna make one big old bowl for one and
let's see what we get with it here we go
this is your girl with some face tune
and then this is how she shows up and
you know what she's still [ __ ] snack I'm
young did this make up for all the old
people references that happened earlier
this already smells delicious and I'm
going to destroy this but before that
you guys have to know that if you want
to sign up for hello fresh you can get
eighty dollars off your first month I'm
talking eight free meals if you go to
hello crash mom and use the offer code
grace helbig eighty again get started at
hello
what are these hint what it what what
why get started and hello fresh calm use
the offer code great something eighty
four eight free meals eighty dollars off
your first month what else do you want
other than like I don't know
solid companionship for the rest of your
life I don't have a code for that but I
got a code for this if you want to eat
your feelings
oh speaking of they're clean oh [ __ ] I
accidentally tasted it while trying to
make a thumb down into berry Peugeot
Bell [ __ ] I guess we do the rest of the
video from here me yeah it's real good
and I knew it and I'm proud of me for
knowing it thank you guys again for
being here for another hellofresh video
I love making these videos I hope you
guys had fun if you did like this video
let me know in the comments down below
who would you discover would you put up
this week better out than in thing I was
gonna say about shrek earlier is that he
seems like some weird combination of
like Tony Robbins and goop oh also I
always forget this every time hello
freshest now from five dollars and 66
cents per serving the best part about
making something delicious when you get
yourself tipsy at the same time it's
like you just made the medicine that you
need for the ailment that you created
for yourself other than that I don't
know
oh it also says if there's excess grease
in your pan that you should dump it out
and that was my review of grease live
expensive just giving I didn't see it
heard great things